this spike we face riding next to the
door flip it
that's the pinger if you put it on that
bone
in
you can hear more connect
aw man Oh it's quite a high-pitch
swallow it sounds like a really high
pitch bird chirping in your ear the same
given off by the tag they're all on a
frequency of 69 kilohertz but then each
tag has its own specific frequencies
based ID so using underwater microphones
you can hear when different sharks are
near buzzes a little yellow boy out
there which actually has a little
tracker on it so every time a tagged
shark swims by it's just like a shark
not checking in daddy
today's a lucky shot Joe in the immortal
I'm here connection to in a minute
connects to satellite lets us know home
when the shark is eating well and at the
same time we also hope to get a tissue
sample from the shark that we tagged why
is that important to grab a tissue
sample a couple of studies we're doing
our looking at the genetic populations
of the different sharks of the world
even
two different genetic populations also
we can work out what the Sharks been in
recently Myers tissue Wow
but before you can tag a shark you have
to entice it close to the boat well it's
morning and we're just about half
breakfast
but I thought I'd come out and have a
look at the Sharks breakfast yeah that
is what we're going to be leaking
overboard to attract the Sharks to our
cages we just threw the bait in and
waited about two minutes and a shark
came up and grabbed it I was trying to
film the seagulls around the bait when
it hit it was incredible just
unbelievable to see how fast they
arrived here so the Sharks are here and
they're biting the goal is not to feed
the Sharks but to pull the bait away
from them before they can get it oh man
that's a big shark
as a storm rolled in it was my chance to
observe the Sharks on their own terms
underwater I'm just trying to make a
nice seal with my mask so I don't get
any water in that means keeps the
Vaseline on my moustache feels
disgusting today we've got pretty stormy
weather and the Sharks are fired up a
bit this is the weather that suits them
for predation with the sea lions grass
pika even thinking Kansas cries ha oh
you like at the tub on me yeah that's a
scuttle babe thank you
thank you
from the cage you can see the sharks
that have already been tagged and you
get a different perspective on what it's
like to pull food away from a shark's
mouth in real time you can see just how
fast they can strike as a pretty
incredible surreal experience to see
drop in there as well another world it's
funny you don't really feel scare them
just maybe it's the cage first you know
they just look so tough solid peaceful
so how hard does it stick when I was in
the dorsal fin if I can get a shark into
really close I get the right shot they
make it pretty easy when they swim past
the best
there it is
poof
you have to be going away
come on aah
with the light fading tagging was put on
hold until tomorrow and that gave me a
chance to talk to the researchers about
why this research is so important before
protection they were hunted for sport
they were hunted for their jaws and they
hunted just out of fear everybody was
scared of sharks
you know the jaws movie the jewels
phenomenon we created an awful lot of or
fear of these animals sharks were
mindless killers some people just wanted
them out of the ocean population numbers
basically crashed and this research is
essential to help their numbers recover
we have to find out how many sharks are
out there we have to find out where they
travel to where they breed that's one of
the Holy Grails and no one knows where
do they give birth we don't know that
either no one's ever seen them breeding
no one's ever seen and given birth and
if you can't protect sharks in those key
areas then you're not going to really be
able to have much of an impact across
the population as a whole
no in it
looking good good looking good
it's great the science you know we've
begin to scratch the surface with
satellite tagging we always thought
white sharks were a coastal species we
found that they are able to do dives
well over a kilometre deep it frequently
dive off the edge of the continental
shelf they go and inhabit measured out
in the open ocean for months and months
and months on end so this whole myth
that they are this coastal creature has
been completely debunked with with the
advent of this new technology it's one
of those things with these animals that
if you ask a question and and you you
conduct your research and you answer
your question and then you have five
more questions that have arisen from
that answer so that's up yeah
then obviously there's a lot more to
learn veritasium is supported by
audible.com a leading provider of
audiobooks with over 150,000 different
titles in all areas of literature
including fiction nonfiction and
periodicals this week I wanted to
recommend a book called
genius the life and science of richard
fineman by James Gleick he is one of my
all-time favorite authors so you should
really check it out in fact you can
download it for free by going to
audible.com/veritasium or you can pick
any other book of your choice for a
one-month free trial so thank you to
audible.com
you don't know I also have a second
channel which is called to veritasium
where I post vlogs and my thoughts on
the world so if you want to check that
out and you can click on this link or
the link in the description so thank you
for watching I'll see you next time